jacques lamblin pour le groupe est
républicain merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
allez-vous bientôt implantée à cherbourg
dont vous avez été maire 5000 migrants
illégaux venant de calais soit 13% de la
population
c'est très précisément la question que
se pose le maire d'une commune de
meurthe-et-moselle
exxon 380 habitants au service envisage
en effet sérieusement d'y implanter 50
migrants illégaux venant de calais soit
13% de la population ce que je décris
n'est pas une simple un simple fait
divers
il illustre concrètement les difficultés
nées d'une approche insuffisante du
problème posé par les flux migratoires
insuffisances européenne c'est sûr mais
aussi insuffisances françaises
je vous rappelle que le gouvernement
français et co gestionnaire de l'espace
de schengen est que depuis trois ans de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent et pas
seulement sur les rangs de l'opposition
dans pour souligner les inacceptables
faiblesses du système schengen
aujourd'hui faute d'avoir traité
sérieusement les causes
le gouvernement en est réduit à imposer
les conséquences à une population rurale
qui n'ayant aucune confiance ne les
accepte pas le monde rural blessée
d'être systématiquement considéré comme
une variable d'ajustement politique
budgétaire sociétal entend qu'on
s'intéresse à lui pour lui proposer
mieux qui est posée qu'est plongée
pardon les crises
pour finir je voudrais dire qu'il faut à
clarifier les choses sur le problème des
sanctions économiques avec la russie
les explications n'ont pas été très
clair merci monsieur le député la parole
est à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur
monsieur le député lambla puisque -
interrogé sur ce que je ferai à
cherbourg je vais vous le dire parce que
lorsque le camp de sangatte a été
démantelée j'ai eu en une nuit
350 migrants à cherbourg dormant dans
des cartons je ne me souviens pas à
l'époque d'avoir poser la moindre
question polémique au gouvernement qui
avait fait cette décision pour des
raisons de dignité pour des raisons de
rigueur pour des raisons d'attachement
au principe de vérité vous me parlez de
deux communes enfin d'une plus
particulièrement la commune de pixon qui
vous dites vous de ce ver est imposée
par l'état l'arrivée de migrants qu'elle
ne souhaiterait pas accueillir c'est
totalement faux je dis solennellement
devant la représentation nationale qu'au
terme de discussions qui ont eu lieu
avec la collectivité locale et le préfet
l'état a renoncé à cette implantation
parce que les conditions n'étaient pas
réunies et que partout nous procédons à
l'accueil de migrants nous le faisons en
dialogue avec les collectivités locales
et je ne comprends pas par conséquent
sur des sujets aussi graves qu'ils
appellent le rassemblement le plus grand
que vous convoquer des contrevérités de
cette nature en laissant à penser à ceux
qui nous écoutent que nous mettrions en
oeuvre une politique que nous ne
mettrons jamais en oeuvre parce qu'elle
ne correspond pas aux instructions que
j'ai donnée au préfet troisièmement pour
être tout à fait clair sur ce que nous
faisons et précis il y à une demande
d'asile en france qu'à diminuer de 2 34%
l'an dernier nous assistons à une
augmentation de la demande d'asile en
france très mesurée en 2015 alors qu'à
une pression démographique que d'une
pression migratoire extrêmement fortes
dans l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne il ya soixante cinq mille
demandes d'asile en france il y en aura
80 milles avant la fin de l'année donc
faire peur avec des chiffres qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité n'est pas
non plus sérieux monsieur lambla je
voudrais profiter de la question pour
rappeler ce que sont les chiffres
enfin dernier point nous sommes dans la
volonté de faire en sorte que tous ceux
qui sont persécutés puisse dans des
conditions de sécurité être accueillis
dignement et que les autres soient
reconduits à la frontière c'est ça la
politique du gouvernement et tout autre
propos ne correspond pas à la réalité de
ce que nous faisons
merci le seul ministre la parole